let's walk through it together okay so
this is number 51 Boro's $10,000 to
pitch his car now straightaway i'm going
to say or ten thousand dollars it looks
like it's a pretty important detail
right so let's write it down the terms
alone our interest is charged at twelve
percent interest per annum twelve
percent though we're looking on page 50
and it's worked example 5 down the
bottom okay yeah top 10 interest at a
lot it's to be repaid in equal monthly
installments equal monthly there's that
word installments what they mean is
that's where payments right here Co
monthly installments how long four years
in four years that's exactly right okay
and now we have a series of questions
what you're going to build on each other
so let's have a good party calculate the
amount of interest that one is charged
okay that's fine that's just like we've
been doing before total amount of
interest i equals p and okay eyes what
we try and find the total amount of
interest right i'm going to take these
pieces that i'm going to sub them in one
at a time right so p the principal
that's how much is morrow which is
10,000 what's the rate i wanted as a
decimal remember there was 0 point 0
everyone to win it yeah be careful
beautiful
nice
hey ma what's in number of number of
years which is four years isn't it okay
so far so good at this point uh yeah I
suppose you could um I suppose you could
get out your calculator I think we don't
need it right let's look at this point
it on the web just to be sure i'm going
to do the steps right I've got ten
powers in here four times point 12 hmm
if I just said 12 all right if I said
twelve times for that's 48 right that'd
be point for H right bless you okay so
what I do their 0.12 and the 44 times 12
is 48 but I've got decimal places their
film group so that's that and now I need
to move the decimal place how many times
need to move it well hold on let me put
some zeros after here I've got four
zeros here right so I'm going to move
the decimal point four times okay watch
which way am I going this decimal point
is going to move this way because the
numbers going to end up you got all
right it's going to go one two three
four times there it is okay so i get
4,800 and you can verify where that with
your calculator it looks reasonable to
me okay or is that part a woman puppy
what's it asking for the total amount
that one must repay toe
we're adding up to things what are we
adding up huh yes that one you know the
one with the guide think we have labels
for all this so use the labels right p
and I that what he's a borrowed 10,000
and the interest that he has to pay for
what he's borrowing right p plus 5 okay
so that's my 10 grand plus 4,800 I just
worked out put them together there you
go do it there you go last part find the
amount of each monthly repayment monthly
repayments now I just put a question
mark there because this is what we're
trying to work out how do I do it right
well this is how much I've got to pay
off or how little earnest to pay off in
total right and he gets four years to do
it how often is he doing it he's doing
it monthly right so for years how many
months are there in four years there are
48 months so that means he has to divide
up this amount of money into 48 equal
chunks right and it's going to pay off
one at a time once every month and
eventually your finish paying with that
okay so to work that out I would say the
monthly you've heard of equals the it's
the total that right divided by the
number months which is which is for you
okay so I'll just get the numbers down
before I get that what was the three
hundred and
is that exact three repeater 33333 like
this 33 and like you yeah okay all right
now quick question how is he going to
like how are we going into account for
like do I have to drive round this after
I ran it down what do I do with it mmm I
heard leave it as one suggestion what do
you reckon I leave it ah good question
now do they say um it doesn't look like
me that they specify right now if you
just had to get he had to guess I think
monthly payments what do you think they
would pay what means by which would they
would they actually repair I would
probably show you mean two dead it's
like it's a funds transfer particularly
for an amount of money ideas I don't I'm
not going to get this amount in cash
probably right and I don't want to
really carry around this amount of cash
every month right and especially since
it happens every month might as well
just set up directly so I'm guessing
that's just what they're going to leave
it as exact that need to round up to
five cents or anything like that there's
your answer okay so like I said the two
differences are number one sometimes
they ask you to work out a different
thing not just the interest they might
want to work out one of these you've
gotta write equation in rearrange or
they might introduce this idea you just
have to work out how many tricks you
have to break it up into